hey everyone I'm Laura Ingram this is
the Ingram angle from Washington tonight
thanks for being with us
now the world is upside down
in the world created by BLM Soros funded
DA's and social media agitators heroes
are held up as villains
and villains they're the new Heroes
now we saw this play out as the Daniel
Penny arrest unfolded Lord knows how
many lies he saved in that subway car
that Jordan Neely was threatening
but the squads of racial arsonists set
his life on fire after Neely died
now Alvin Bragg's office is after the
two other brave men who jumped in to
help Mr Penny subdue the crazed lunatic
now we witness the same perverse
Insanity in the open border crisis
caused by Joe Biden
the media loves the fraudulent Asylum
Seekers flooding our country routinely
amplifying their wants their needs their
concerns and taking everything they say
about their cases
it's just it's gospel gotta believe it
so ranchers in Texas Property Owners
tired of the trash and all the resources
this is consuming well they're just
heartless nativists
so villainizing Americans who say no
more migrants became more difficult
though this week when minorities in
cities like New York and Chicago they
began protesting as well
these families and in some cases they're
adult males I don't feel safe having
adult males with no Health screenings no
criminal background checks around around
our children and in some cases they
can't come out and play this is unfair
resources that have not come to us now
you want to overly compensate for people
who never lived here before we have been
Redland Jim Crow pushed out enough
now what are the sensible Democrats
telling Biden look this is out of
control shut this down just a merely
political concerns at this point
we're the honest journalists demanding
accountability and answers about what
this is doing to communities that are
underserved and already under pressure
and then there's the case of a
physician's assistant at Bellevue
Hospital in New York now she's six
months pregnant and had just wrapped up
a 12-hour shift and she decided to hop a
city bike you can rent those to commute
home
now the bike by the way she reserved for
their credit card it was hers
now when she tried to undock the bike a
group of young men and teens approached
her one of them slamming the bike back
down into its little station
now that's when these thugs turned the
camera back on
recorder
please
all right so why don't we set reset the
bike
my clients
the baby gonna come out with something
how you stop crying
not a two came down
the video went viral it spread like
Wildflower fire and white woman berating
or you know fight needless fight with a
group of black men that was the perfect
crystallization of what the radicals
want everyone to believe
of course that white people hate that
black people just she's another Karen
that's what the mob was crying well the
video quickly racked up tens of millions
of views and The Usual Suspects in
social media hell began to throw
kerosene on the fire and deep thinker
Benjamin Crump even tweeted a white
woman was caught on camera attempting to
steal a city bike from a young black man
in New York City she grossly tried to
weaponize her tears to paint this man as
a threat this is exactly the type of
behavior that has endangered so many
black men in the past
well Crump just deleted the Tweet today
that's good but the damage has been done
now in a predictable fashion the
corporate cowards at Bellevue Hospital
without doing its own investigation of
what happened put her on leave
this statement read the incident in the
video is disturbing and then it went on
to suggest that she was somehow
profiling these individuals
here was her attorney earlier with Bill
hemmer
she's received death threats you know
her family has been she's in hiding you
know what's that play is what social
media did to this woman who is literally
a hero and has done nothing but help
people and within one minute effectively
tries to ruin her could this just have
been an ugly miscommunication
um I mean that that's all effectively
this is race has nothing to do with it
if the skin colors were the same we
would not be here today
now his client has produced the receipt
showing that indeed the bike was hers to
use not theirs
and it sure seems to look like the real
villains here are the jerks who harass
this woman and everyone else who just
piled on
and it's a disgusting commentary on what
the far left and their media
conspirators have done to our country
I think these are isolated incidents by
the way that's what everyone's saying
because millions of Americans who are
hard-working they're good people they're
beginning to feel like they have a
Target on their back simply because they
don't fit the current liberal ideal
now this woman feels like her life is
just over
so shame on everyone who helped ignite
this Firestorm shame on Bellevue for
treating a diligent employee a health
care worker we're supposed to celebrate
them aren't we
to treat them this way
this has all got to stop or America is
gonna head down a very dangerous road
and perhaps one we will not be able to
turn back on hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else